i want to know because you were in the
hole solitary confinement for six years
six and a half years think about it
they put them in the like you're alone
bro and then in the winter time you get
one hour a week to go out in the yard
i'm sure the food's great you're so
alone he was so desperate he grabbed
this nurse's finger just to talk to him
for a second my question is
how did you speak to yourself how do you
[ __ ] stay the same toughness yeah get
through that how did you not go crazy
yourself in three minutes yeah i was
asked this question a lot of times but
i'm gonna answer it
that
we all
have no idea
how much we have in us
if something that we can't control like
a plane crashes and we're stuck on a
[ __ ] island yeah we have you have no
idea how much you could withdraw from
your body to survive and to do certain
things and you know but being in the
hole like that
i mean it was the worst time of my life
six and a half years i just it was
incredible but i did i knew they wanted
to break me yeah and that was my mental
frame so i did sit-ups i did push-ups i
did crunches i talked to myself and i
called it the adx strut would walk
around the cell talking to myself
answering myself
and
trying any of everything i had one visit
while i was in the adx my wife came down
she's my ex-wife now
and she came on a visit
and i went there
and uh
it's a booth i go into a booth
she's on the other side in a booth
my side faces the president her side
faces those machines and stuff and
they came with lunch
they opened the slot pushed the tray in
i got it and it says hey there's no
utensils
they close the slot eat with your hands
all right
i said deb go in the machines and get
what you want
you have to talk on a phone the glass is
so thick you can't hear it over my head
there's a camera looking at her over her
head there's a camera looking at me
so i'm sitting there and i'm eating
a phone
on my cheek talking her and eating with
my hands
and she's talking that her voice blurred
away from me not that it was i couldn't
hear it as mentally i said
look what i'm becoming a total [ __ ]
animal
she's sitting
there i'm in the cage she's in a cage
and i'm eating [ __ ] food with my
hands and i don't even have nothing to
wipe it on
i says
what a mistake this [ __ ] visit is
i hit the buzzer a little bit
the female guard came up what is it
i got to go to the bathroom
all right
put your hands through the
slot i put my hands through she cuffed
my hands i come out
she takes me in the hole i walk down the
hall at the end of the hall there's this
chicken wire like you know regular yeah
around this
area and a bowl against the wall that's
it
no barriers no nothing
so i went in there i uncuffed
sean cuffed me to a slot and i went in
and i says uh
could you go down the hall a little bit
she said i have to stand here and watch
i said i don't have to take a piss i
have to take a [ __ ]
please could you go down the hall
i have to stand here this camera's there
i can't walk away
it's the first time in my life
i [ __ ] in front of a woman
it was so [ __ ]
i was demoralized yeah that'll do it
yeah i mean i never felt like that i was
so humiliated i was
i was literally sick
to my stomach and i i never did that in
my life
i didn't feel between eating with my
hands and now this i didn't feel like a
human being anymore
i felt like a total [ __ ] animal and
did you have regrets of the lifestyle at
that point well when i left and i got
back in
i got in there i got the phone i told my
wife i said listen babe
you spent about two thousand with
airfare hotel you're gonna be here too
that don't let anybody come here and
don't come back
i don't ever want another visit here
again
don't come back
it's just saying you're getting one call
a month
one [ __ ] call a month and they're on
the phone they're listening they can
shut you down you
you got to have a call you got to be
human you have kids at this point too oh
i got kids yeah yeah they always had
kids so
that was it i never got another visit i
told her please just don't i didn't
explain to her
what
just took
happened when i went to the bathroom
and uh i'm married
i had girlfriend i never went to the
bedroom like that no in my life how to
ask for a male girl hey can we get the
male guard yeah right
now
you're not going to give us just like i
told her i didn't you know what that you
know
i was going to take a [ __ ] i figured she
would walk away anyway
i don't think she's happy about it i
didn't know she don't want to let you
take a [ __ ] that's her shop sucks too
yeah yeah both
it was a hard fought that's a shitty job
i mean no pun intended yeah that's no
pun intended what he's talking about now
i became so
hungry for conversation
that a female nurse came she i i liked
how she was friendly she was a nice
woman seemed like a nice person
she was talking about a letter that my
daughter had sent and she was had the
letter in her hand she was
your daughter's a good writer and she
was talking about this that and the
other thing and uh
she handed it to me through the buzz and
i and i got it and i was reading it a
little bit and she was talking to me
about it
and uh she says all right i'm gonna go
and i have to give her a letter back
when i gave her the letter back she took
her with one hand
and
she said i'm gonna go
i don't even know what made me do it i
swear to god i'm trying to think what
made me do i had no idea but i grabbed
her finger
i went to grab my hand but i grabbed the
finger and i said i begged her not to
leave to talk to me
and uh she said say i mean there's
cameras all over
i know what you're going through
if they see you hanging onto my hand
she didn't try to pull and fight
because they would have saw that yeah
she said they'll come and
beat your [ __ ] brains in
i know what you're going through they're
overdoing it with you
please let go my finger
and i let go
i said i wasn't trying to hurt you
she said i know
do push-ups do
sit-ups meditate
[ __ ] them
that's how good of a person he says yeah
stay strong i will come back and forth
and talk to you
make it
don't let them break you jesus can
there's no there was no way your lawyers
could say this guy's in i mean he's in
the hole for six [ __ ] years
the government doesn't care
no listen choppo's in there already now
he got [ __ ]
he's going crazy who is choppa el chapo
they give him i don't think he gets an
hour outside he is no don't give him an
hour he's going crazy his wife uh who's
in prison now too but she submit thing
to the the prison like he's legit going
insane of course and they go yeah how do
you think this works